[Music]
i have with me
david pakman he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program the
david pacman
show and i wanted to talk to david
pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse well we gotta that's a
lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
pacman he is a beta girl
david pacman
all right guys let's cut it because we
do have breaking news to get to
we have another one of these completely
delusional rudy giuliani hearings take a
listen to this
um just keep in mind we still have got a
dozen witnesses to here
and it's uh 3 30. whoa hold on a second
i just wanted to revisit um what you
were saying as far as
you got to a point where you to say
that they didn't know where these trucks
and ballots were coming from
they didn't it's not that they didn't
know is that they didn't know how many
were still coming
okay um i assume at this point in time
these were not
early ballots okay so we're gonna
primarily be listening to rudy giuliani
and it's anyone's guess whether he's
going to be making a fool out of himself
merely for what he says or also because
of how he looks
it's always unclear but this is going to
be completely outrageous this one is
happening in arizona the one i covered
with you last week was happening in
georgia in
pennsylvania and what's hilarious about
these events
is there's never any evidence of voter
fraud
presented there's no evidence of fraud
fraud
or freud which we've heard all
interchangeably if you look at the
emails that i've been getting from trump
supporters
um they just never present it because
they don't have it
and when you look at the court filings
that they've done
they don't actually allege voter fraud
in the court filings because they know
they don't have evidence so these are
dog and pony shows
but rudy giuliani is running them at
this point
and they are just a hilarious train
wreck to see
and donald trump keeps promoting them if
you look at donald trump's twitter
account
he has pinned a live feed from this
event that we are watching
and earlier today tweeted trump legal
team in
arizona and on oan now
big stuff enjoy so trump is promoting it
as much as anybody
else even though according to people
around trump
he realizes that uh this is not actually
going to give him a path to victory
and even more so it uh is making him
look stupid so let's just listen to a
little bit more here
one witness and i have much more
butchering your name man
but uh if you would could you properly
pronounce it um
give us just 10 seconds of what you plan
to tell us and if you could keep it
within 10 minutes yeah
thank you for having me here today my
name is greg wadinski
i'm uh obviously an american citizen and
obviously
in maricopa county i want to
talk to you a little bit about what i
observed
as a certified poll observer
election observer down at the maricopa
county
m-tech facility of the tabula guys i'm
pretty sure this is convicted felon
bernie carrick can anybody confirm that
for me is this actually bernie carrick
in the audience bernard carrick
somebody could fact check that for me
that would be even more outrageous
chain of custody and what i would
discuss or describe as the ability of
fluidity or porous administration
on the system um
as i mentioned i was an observer at
mtech on
1024 and then again a week later
on sunday 11 1 before election day i
spent approximately
now rudy's moving and bernie it was
almost like bernie was gonna go i i
think that that's bernie carrick i'm
telling you guys
the paperwork to be there was badged and
i had the ability to
move about the m-tech tabulation room
um i was in the area where they were
doing adjudication work
and then later on the sunday the 11th
excuse me sunday the first okay so this
guy's going to figure out what dates all
of these things happened on
i i want to get caught this is going to
go on for a while and we're going to
primarily focus in on the claims that
rudy makes because
the witnesses are just endless and
anyway you guys you guys understand
um a couple different things number one
um i don't know if you guys are aware of
massive dumps
but it is what donald trump is now
blaming for his election loss so i do
want to play
uh just a couple of clips for that
donald trump did a completely
humiliating interview
with maria bartoromo yesterday who now
is indistinguishable from
the north korean uh broadcasters who
report
that kim jong-un doesn't defecate
speaking of which
donald trump now is blaming massive
dumps for losing to joe biden take a
listen to this
and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
saying congratulations political people
yeah congratulations sir you just won
the election
it was 10 o'clock and you looked at the
numbers and i'm sure you felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps uh in missions i love
the
the timing of the glasses of judgment as
adjustment when trump
blames massive dumps for his email loss
she has
she she just adjusts the glasses like
now i this i'm gonna need my glasses for
let
me just go back and play that one more
time because it's you couldn't script
anything more comedic than this this
election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps
uh in michigan and pennsylvania
and uh all over yeah they were doing
dumps all over the place and next thing
you know donald trump lost
how insane is this how insane
is that this is what the president is
alleging um let me just look at one more
clip here uh where was this one
not the dominion clip not this one
um where was it oh this is just genius
maria bartoromo comes up with the
brilliant idea that if you just don't
count the
the votes from swing states trump won
critical part of this story mr president
but
if you take out the contested swing
states
electoral votes take them out uh you're
back down to
president trump having 232 electoral
votes and joe biden having 227
that is if you strip out the six states
with the legal challenges
listen and by the way legal challenges
the legal we see
when they say legal challenges it's this
guy
the legal challenges are based on listen
this is this is a legal challenge that
they based this on patients were being
fed into the computer system within that
room
and there was an assurity that there
seemed to be a level of physical as well
as
uh network security based on the
arrangement of those computer systems
the arrangement of the computers leads
to biden
one apparently so when they say legal
challenges that's what they're talking
about
if we just willy-nilly say let's
be because understand the logic this is
cer i hope people understand the
circular
reasoning here they file lawsuits
that are bogus in these six states and
then
maria says listen these six states are
contested
if you don't count them because they're
contested
you're in the lead mr president but why
aren't you counting them oh bill because
trump himself filed the lawsuits
just don't count pennsylvania don't
count georgia michigan arizona wisconsin
nevada
take all of those states out and trump's
actually in the league
is the thinking here that because of the
various ballot
issues right that the supreme court will
rule that the vote is tainted
and that will mean that they have to
take votes away from they've tinted it
off white
biden and not certified is that the
thinking and secondly
what's your timing on this mr president
because we've got some notes
how soon do you think you'll defeat
biden well election dates here that i
want to ask you
what you believe you consider to be your
drop dead date
in terms of proving this case yeah is it
december 18th
when the states finalize elector
appointments or when electors cast votes
in each state
is it the vice president receiving
electoral votes is it the house and
senate counting electoral votes
or is it inauguration why is she
screaming also okay
january 20th how do you see it well i
don't want to give you an
actual date a lot of people say the 18th
or they say the 14th or but notice by
this is the funniest thing
okay i really need you guys to
understand something trump has no clue
what the dates are
you know how we know that maria
bartoromo misspoke and said december
18th when as you can see on screen it
actually says december 8th
she misspoke and said december 18th
trump
because he has no idea he doesn't
realize
december 18th isn't the date that she
was referring to it's not even a real
date
but trump also says december 18th i hope
you guys caught that
she just said december 18th because she
thought that's what december 8th said
and then trump says a lot of people are
talking about december 18th
nobody's talking about december 18th
maria is the only person because she
misread the graphic
a lot of people say the 18th or they say
the 14th or they say january 20th
no that nobody is talking about december
18th
other than maria bartiromo herself so
a bizarre absolutely bizarre
interview and uh again the big headline
that donald trump is blaming
massive dumps all over the place
i i know people people probably expect
this to be you know a straightforward
stream and they're tuning in and they
hear me talking about
massive dumps all over the place the
president said it
okay the president said it and just
because we had like 5 000 people tune in
while we were doing this
let me just play it for you uh for you
one more time
oh hold on i was called by the biggest
people
uh saying congratulations political
people
congratulations sir you just won the
election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
yeah she did this election was over and
then they did dumps
they call them dumps big massive dumps
uh in michigan and pennsylvania
and uh uh all over uh if they were doing
them all over
and it was absolutely vile and
disgusting um
okay so that is the case the president
is making at this point in time here we
are back in arizona where it is
a maskless event during which rudy
giuliani
is apparently making the case that there
there is fraud now a couple things let
me just get to a few super chats and
then we're going to continue with some
other elements here
chakuseki says david can you appeal to
your talented songwriting friends for
someone to sample
trump's massive dumps quote for a new
bang and tune
if there is anything that needs to be
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if
you can include we released the clip
about this about an hour
ago hour and a half ago if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it so this goes out to um
physic and joseph woodward and
jethro bradley you know all of these um
music creators that i think would do
really really really well if it were to
be remixed and
sampled let's get back to rudy what does
that all lead you to
at least hypothetically
conclude well i think my biggest concern
would be that we've been hearing
from election officials and others just
a little closer yeah
i think we've been hearing from election
officials and others
about the sanctity and the security of
this system the sanctity
we've been here we must preserve the
sanctity of voting you know
coming and going and one of the most
i guess basic premises of any kind of
security would be physical security
and by having that disk drive copied
and then shuffled off the premises
presumably
by this gentleman's statement without a
chain of custody
that's no different than ballots in a
box
red or unread coming and going without
any
supervision so this dominion employee
took now they're on dominion
could have taken him anywhere and could
have done anything with him that he
wanted
notice that everything is anything could
have happened in this election
we just don't know okay well how how
long are you going to keep saying
anything could have happened without
putting forth an idea as to what did
happen
his job was to make that copy so why why
is there a chain of custody
i would imagine there's a chain of
custody so that we can prove
that the data has not changed and it
arrived at its intended destination
un unhandled and on on you know
you know untainted or any kind of
malicious activity performed on it
and and this was a dominion employee who
did who did this
that's correct and any of the county
is anybody even under oath here like is
it is this
is this even relevant in any way to any
kind of legal proceeding
i know they talk about sworn affidavits
but is this is this testimony
even legally relevant in any way does
anybody know no everybody thinks it's
not
yeah okay that seems to be that seems to
be it okay a few other super chats while
we continue to look here
do you think generally speaking a
professor of physics or philosophy is
more intellectual
uh that those seem like uh semantic
labels i i i'm not sure
chakaseki says donald jr on the other
hand is always on the lookout for
massive
bumps sniff sniff nick says diaper don
has mastered dumps in his diaper
oh my god um a lot of messages about
this
danny says that this probably is bernie
carrick he was definitely with rudy
at the four seasons landscaping fiasco
yeah i think that is bernie carrick
and ian says what does intellectual mean
philosophy econ and law degree here
there are deep critical thinkers and
baffoons in all of these fields well
said
maybe biden should contest texas and
florida then we can throw those results
out too
right like at what point is this people
just saying i'm not really sure what
happened
joe says is the lady in the in the back
wearing rubber pants
related to massive dumps i don't know i
don't know who that is i don't know if
that's rubber vinyl or leather
uh remains to be seen dress sanchez says
what software do you use to show the
video and yourself separately as well as
audio
um streamlabs obs is what we use
denise's can you pick out the person
that just came from the bondage session
yeah i assume you're referring to the
vinyl
or plastic pants uh shock there's half a
barrel of oil in these pants if you can
imagine that
very very hard to believe but but
accurate
very very accurate okay um
we are continuing to watch this i guess
we're calling it testimony i don't know
it's not under oath and it's not legally
relevant in any way let's listen to a
little more
he told me that he was doing this daily
so every night he would take out
the drive with him he would make a copy
to the main
what i call the what he called the
orange drive in the cage in the security
area
and then make a second copy for this
off-site copy
which would then allegedly move out of
the mtech facility
a legend destination and when you
objected to it
what what happened um i guess i really
didn't overreact
i was there as an observer and i guess
it wasn't my question
you know my i did feel it was my
position to um
get confrontational about it and i just
quietly made my observations and
duly noted them to the proper
authorities dooley is there anything
else you noted about
the facility um
yeah i had to flush the toilet 15 times
just like trump said some
publications around the county's
installation of the facility and the
idea that it provides
a level of transparency to the community
it's visible if you have access to the
building the server is visible
my concerns though would be that
i don't i can't say with you know
because i just don't know
right whether or not by just looking
at that facility and looking at the way
the hey by the way
how are they even holding an event
indoors where masks aren't mandatory at
this point like what parts of the
country are remaining at this point
where you can do an event like this with
no masks at all
it's very strange 15 maybe even more
than
20 people working on adjudication in
there as well as the staff from the
county
so when they were when they were taking
the the copy making the copy
did they do any uh data checks before
uh removing the drives wow what
that question was just handed to to rudy
by jenna ellis
brutal question my question to the
to the employee in his answer didn't
include any speculation around that
understand like how they're manipulating
this
this is one of those things where i can
come to you at any time actually
let me get back to that hold on
representative roberts thank you mr
chairman
um sir you mentioned earlier that you
said that uh you reported your concerns
okay senator they're gonna ask so that's
one of those things where you know
crafty lawyers
will often do it we could be talking
about
you know this happens a lot actually in
medical malpractice
um uh claims and and uh testimony
where there will be a malpractice claim
about
a hip replacement for example and it
could be legitimate it might not it's
being it's being evaluated
and there will be some standard practice
as to
how you prepare a patient for hip
replacement and all these different
things and to be clear this is not a
defense of anybody in particular
but a clever lawyer who wants to make
the the surgeon
look bad will come in and say uh you
know uh
dr dr giuliani did you
check the uh june 2015
new england medical journal report about
uh hip replacement adverse reactions
for people who have had too much
grapefruit juice
and it could be you know completely
irrelevant to the thing
but you the idea is you put the doctor
in a position to say no i didn't look at
that
really and then later you go to a jury
and you say
dr giuliani did you not under oath tell
me you did not look
at that article about interactions
between grapefruit and hip replacement
that's true i did oh
right you're trying to create that type
of gotcha moment and when rudy giuliani
says
did they let you know they were doing
data checks
how is that even remotely relevant to
work to whether joe biden won they're
trying to
create something to to get they didn't
do data checks
oh oh my god no data checks can you
imagine guys it's meaningless it's
meaningless let's listen to this next
witness briefly
and by the way i'm using the term i'm
using the term witness very loosely
2020 election is voting irregularities
inequities lack of transparency
and contested voter results
i'm also here as a veteran a military
veteran
and wish to thank you for your service
how is that relevant
our military men and women that serve to
keep the united states of america
a free constitutional republic a nation
of constitutional laws
checks and balances and
it's kind of weird that oh
my god
and to all of our military branches
it was weird that he said he's there as
a veteran and then talked about the
constitution it's like shouldn't
shouldn't constitutional lawyers be
commenting on the constitution
and how is veteran status or the
constitution
relevant to whether joe biden won
arizona like do you guys understand how
weird this all is
responsible for financial operations
mergers and acquisitions
audits that were both general audits
and forensic audits banking
tax and legal relationships with
barrister solicitors and attorneys
internationally
barristers following is my declaration
as well as a copy of my
poll observer authorization form
which i brought with me to show you
bernie carrick is just like what the
hell am i even doing here
what what am what is this why am i even
here
required to present to poll inspectors
at each of the poll locations where i
was assigned to observe
also i have a picture of the bar
elementary
school gymnasium that was a polling
location where i served
on november the third he noticed that it
was very irregular
they were advertising at the bake sale
after you vote
brownies and they were blondies
completely
irregular naming of baked goods from an
assigned
seat at the entrance of the gym and not
be able to see
any of the ballots or the actual
processing
that was located at the opposite end of
the gym
everybody knows what a school gym looks
like but i thought i'd bring a picture
just to make certain that you
got it
oh my god that that's why
that's why everybody should should be
wearing masks
dear god uh was that rudy in the
background there
united methodist church in uh sun lakes
arizona
it's it's too perfect guys from 5 30 a.m
to 3 30 p.m at the bar elementary school
in phoenix
and then from four o'clock to 7 15
at the sun lakes methodist church in sun
lakes arizona
while serving as an observer i
personally witnessed the following
observers were not allowed to talk with
poll workers or voters
which was part of the manual that the
secretary of state
had put out now you know one of these
things about the term
not allowed that's being thrown around
what do they mean by that like was that
let's imagine that that's true in some
way they weren't allowed
by uh by police they were physically
restrained like what does it mean they
weren't allowed
areas of the voting uh to be able to
observe them
at the um sun lakes location i was
seated about 25 feet away from the
tabulation the tabulating machine
in my ballot uh box dropbox
and i had to ask the poll inspector it
had to be
accompanied by a poll worker if i wanted
to walk around
to observe anything anywhere in the
polling locations
in the bar elementary school i was
seated about
80 feet from the two tabulator machines
and the ballot uh dropbox and i had to
ask the poll inspector
who was at the opposite end of the
gymnasium and i was only sober maybe
twice during the
time i was there from the morning until
uh four o'clock in the afternoon
um if i was if i wanted to walk around
uh and i had to be accompanied by a pole
worker to observe anything anywhere in
the poll location
okay so we're gonna put so so we're just
taking it this has been going on for
eight hours
so we're just taking a sampling of
different things rudy is coming back and
we're gonna hear from rudy soon
and and it's all it's all very
interesting a few
other um super chats coming in
the battle master says i'm english and
i'm just getting out of lockdown
and i feel so sorry for americans they
got a president who doesn't even want to
give up his power like a dictator
and i thought our government was screwed
kyle says hey i have pictures guys so
obviously fraud
big daddy wants to argue as a veteran as
a military veteran that kanye west won
the election well
good sir that is your right to do
um maria wants the audio samplers to
include
trump ranting about flushing toilets if
you do a remix about trump talking about
massive dumps
i think that's a good idea i think
that's a really good idea let me just
say a few thank yous
the font peg subscribed with twitch
prime
and says amazing that they keep letting
rudy go out in public
keep up the good fight david uh yeah
we have a report tomorrow about um
claims that
people around trump are telling him
rudy's making you look like an idiot
but um trump seems to not be listening
because he's still
he's still promoting these events i do
want to say
thanks to the 2209
to the 12 people that got twitch subs
while we've been chatting here and also
a big thank you to helena paulo kangas
who signed up at joinpacman.com
and theresa is that keller theresa
keller who signed up at jointpakman.com
uh people asking about
phones i i would love to open phones
today
but uh we would we're gonna have to
stick to our goal of a hundred website
members and twitch subs
we actually the last week has been very
rough
coronavirus is crushing people and i am
getting
about 25 to 30 emails a day
of people saying david i'm sorry i have
to cancel my membership i
i've lost my job uh my business my work
is still
shut down because of the virus and i
understand we are not
essential spending i totally get that
but it's it's sad what's going
on so if you are not in that position i
know there's lots of folks who have done
actually
really well during during the pandemic i
would love for you to grab a
subscription at joinedpakman.com it's
the most direct
uh way of supporting the work that we do
we have much planned for 2021 and
i would love for you to grab a
subscription at joinpakman.com every you
know we we
end we estimate that only about .7
of our audience subscribes in any kind
of financial way and that's fine
we want to do the show for everybody
right we'll the 0.7 are subsidizing the
99.3
and that's great uh but i would love for
you to grab a membership at
joinpakman.com we have this
great new coupon code fresh start this
the coupon code
will likely be outlawed under the biden
administration
it's too big of a discount so i
encourage you to take advantage of it
right now
70 off fresh start and i will do my best
to thank
everybody that signs up uh but but in
all seriousness
all the people who are saying i'm a
member i'm a member i'm a member
i love it i love it and i very much uh
appreciate that
and we will continue thanking people we
will get back to the testimony at the
conclusion of this
witness we are expecting rudy to sort of
uh
ask some questions and maybe refocus
some elements of this
and that i think would be very
interesting i do hope since this is my
first time back then since thanksgiving
we are going to get back to the meat of
this
but i hope everybody had a great
thanksgiving if you follow me on
instagram you would have seen
uh nemo the dog nemo the dog
begging for my grapes over thanksgiving
and you know what's funny
people immediately started sending me
messages saying
david you do not give the dog grapes
grapes can be toxic to dogs
david no don't give him the grapes
and so i had to clarify i am not giving
him any grapes
everybody relax everybody relax
um but nemo the dog very
very anxious for some of my grapes and
in the meantime
the coronavirus numbers are absolutely
insane
40 people just died while we've been
talking we
uh saw this dip in cases and deaths
which i believe is due just to the
holiday weekend
um and i think that we are going to see
the numbers probably pick back back
up in the next few days as the data is
all processed
as you can see today another 131 000
cases
and about a thousand deaths and i think
we are still waiting for a few states
colorado idaho new mexico oregon
new hampshire um still waiting on so the
the numbers are absolutely vile i mean
it's it's it's insane
let's get to rudy's questioning now
serve the green button
it was while i was uh a poll of poll
watcher at the as a
voting at the voting location at the
poll okay well explain to me the green
button
the green button is a button that's
labeled cast
never press the green button c-a-s-t it
is a triangular shape button
and there is a uh another button that's
on the machine right next to it
which is launched that
was a button that was used for uh other
issues
but it wasn't forecasting the ballot
if they wanted to reject the the ballot
they pushed the rectangular button
and this guy's got to get on mic so as i
understand it the
reason that the green light would show
up is because the machine wasn't
accepting
uh the ballad there was some issue with
the valley now whether there was you'd
think a red light would signify a
problem it's weird to make the green
light the
something's really wrong color it had
rejected
the ballot but i had observed
from the distance that i was at that so
many
times that green button that green
triangular button he had to be pushed
that it seemed to me like it was almost
a requirement that they had to do that
in order to be able to put a balancer
imagine if all this time green button
just means the ballot's been counted
press the green button well the green
button
did accept the ballot it pushed it
through
but it put the ballot then into a drawer
which they uh noted as droid number
three
which separated that from the ballots
that were accepted which went into
drawer number one and number two
so all those ballots that went number
three i don't know what happened to them
were they put aside for further
inspection
i don't know this guy is
damn sure that a green button that's
triangular kept being pressed
but he doesn't know exactly why
and he doesn't know what was done when
that
button needed to be pressed special
boxes just for them
for numbers i don't know if the drawer
number three went into a special box
because i wasn't able to observe that
and get close enough to see that
uh but i know that the ballots then were
all supposed to be taken
to a another location where it was a
central location
in uh the east valley uh in arizona
uh where they were going to be picked up
by a white panel truck
the fact that it's a white panel truck
is one of those irrelevant details like
wait a second they took the ballots from
number box number three that triggered
a green triangular button in a white
paneled truck to east valley arizona
holy [ __ ]
period that there were times during the
day usually it was like about two
o'clock in the afternoon
where a truck would come a van
van type truck a panel truck a van type
truck full location
there were two representatives that
would come in that had
name tags on them was it a banner a
truck uh
take the ballots and uh i happened to
follow that out they would take the
pellets put it into a
box a plastic box and they would take
them out to their truck
well in one case i followed them out was
it a van like truck or a truck like van
i want to know what it was
that they had he had a california plane
highly irregular
truck that's for sure yeah and that they
were renting
trucks locally so there could have been
that there were
enough people moving from california
they were using those trucks
right they were just movers are you
referring now just to the
ballots that were the subject of the
green button that went into number three
these were just
all the ballots these were all the
ballots they were balanced so they were
transporting the ballots essentially is
what he's saying
from out of the machines and the green
ballots were taken along with
green ballots okay and now you also said
that how many ballots approximately
do you think were cast that way that you
observed
well in each day when i was there prior
to the actual election day
um there were probably
several hundreds of thousands of people
that filed through that particular
how many several hundreds to thousands
rudy for a second perked up and thought
he was going to get this guy to say
hundreds of thousands of people like 400
000
and he perked up there i don't know if
you guys noticed but then the guy said
well
hundreds or thousands of people over the
entire time
like wait wait a second that's it when
when you were when you were at the
maricopa county election facility
where the ballots were received
validated and processed
uh you were seated 25 feet
in front of a room with 110 ballot
processes
could you see anything no i mean i could
see the people like this
did you observe could you observe
signatures or
not at all you know what's so stupid
about this if he was
five feet from 25 poll workers
how does one person monitor what 20 what
25
people are doing anyway like it
you what you're going like this in a
circle it doesn't make any sense
and they would just go through that long
aisle way
and set them off on the side other than
that i was not able to talk to anybody i
was not able to see anything
i was not able to examine anything so as
a poll observer
i was really hindered by just being
there and not being able to
he was hindered by merely being there
that's the line of the night my friends
uh again there were 110 of them so they
were spread 110
tables yes and how many observed and i
would say the room was probably
as large as this room how many observers
republican observers
well i was the only you were the only
only public observer
on the republican side while at 110
110 processors
110 tables no 110 processors
shouldn't rudy like proffer the witness
and get the figure out the testimony
first
and i was the only new republican
observer and you have only two eyes
right
there you have more than two eyes
unless i'm wearing my glasses with
everybody then you have four okay
so i mean you couldn't see anything no
could not see anything they could have
been they could have been putting phony
ballots in and you wouldn't have known
the difference absolutely
reportedly that truck van that was
highly irregular
and moved the ballots they didn't even
refrigerate the ballots if you can
imagine they were
what they call spoiled ballots it's wild
uh okay kyle asking how much does it
cost to ruin your reputation 20
000 a day yeah trump paying rudy 20
grand a day to ruin his reputation
um jeffrey says he's contradicting
himself he's so far away he couldn't see
anything but he can see the green
ballots go in drawer number three
guys yes he was across the room and that
triangular green button was so
big that it was just very clear to him
what was going on um thank you to the
25 new subscribers
over on twitch which puts us at 39. i
know a lot of people
very anxious to get the phone lines
opened
let me see here how we are doing from
the standpoint of website memberships we
had two
we are now at 18. that's 16
which puts us at 55. uh yes i will
open phone lines we have a very modest
goal
of 100 website members and twitch subs
and i would um i would love to do it now
here is a relevant question a lot of
people in in twitch chat
are saying rudy is billing 20 grand a
day
but is trump really paying him because
trump is known for not paying
contractors
that's an absolutely appropriate
question i've been asking myself the
same thing
raise an issue about that no i didn't
because i didn't know whether
anything that was going on there was
proper or not proper i was only there
for one day and i was just observing to
see
what questions i did want to ask which i
asked a few questions
as well as that i realized that i was
not able to
actually see the process coming
where the trucks come in unload the
ballots see what was going on in the
mail room
how they uh how they um how they process
through
the ballot it was just one day of that
one day i was there for one day
rudy's making a note in votes a day yes
correct
and then you mentioned uh that 35 people
signed under penalty of perjury
something about the green
yes the green button button would you
explain that one more time so
they said they found it to be a shade of
blue it wasn't even green
the arizona gop had received many many
calls
and complaints from voters about the
fact that they
felt that their
when they checked their belly hadn't
been counted
so they were wondering what happened to
it so they wanted to know how they can
check to see if their ballots were
actually counted or what happened to
them
as a result of that the arizona gop
had asked for volunteers to come in to
make calls back to these people these
voters
to find all over the valley to find out
what
the issues were that they had
encountered what i hadn't covered that i
just testified to
was they had many of the the idea of
calling this testimony i find it
sort of problematic you picked up their
affidavits
so i was able to talk to not only the
phone but talk to them
uh person person um that they had
told me that the experience they had was
that
the um they brought their ballot up to
the machine the
uh they put it into the machine the poll
worker that was there
when the green light went on the polar
worker that was there
told them to push the green button and
they did and the machine accepted their
ballot
but yet it wasn't counted yeah
earlier he said he didn't know whether
it was or wasn't counted when this green
button thing happened
um is that you mr armageddon mr
mr please that is carrying
mr chairman this is a clear something up
for us here from your testimony sir
okay i don't know if anybody else
noticed but there were three drawers
and and i'm confused what do we need
three drawers for
if um so my question is
the two drawers that were there how were
those
ballots separated and why were
votes for the presidential candidates
were they separated by that for two
drawers
was uh they separated for the
county supervisor races why was there a
need for two drawers
if the ballot went through the machine
everything was good why true drawers do
you know the answer to that
no i don't you know a lot of these
questions could be answered just by
asking
the vote the act not poll observers ask
the counties that are running the
election and the manufacture of the
machines why are there two drawers like
you don't need a hearing to ask this guy
that
his work okay thank you
next question i have was that
did you witness in any of your
uh and thank you for your work by the
way did you witness
anything like the testimony we have
heard today
where the lowering of standards
on the site for signature verifications
for any mail-in ballots
worthy like why would you be asking of a
glorified volunteer
how the voting machines work ask the
people who made the machines
so my answer to that would be i don't
know right
perfect thank you thank you mr chairman
mr roberts you know when i had my
driving test with a massachusetts state
police officer
after when we got back and he was done
with his day of running these tests
he put the different applications for
licenses
into two different drawers and i
immediately found that suspicious
referring to earlier
i wasn't allowed to see any part of the
receiving process
where the trucks would come to the
building they would be unloaded
they would go into the mail receiving
room
the mail receiving room should have been
able to separate the ballots by whatever
method
they would use to separate them they
were then supposed to go through a slice
engine
and these were things that i was told
but we were not actually able to see
them
no so he's testifying to hear so he
that's hearsay that's the definition he
was told things he didn't see
you also said something earlier that uh
you were not allowed
you participated in 2016 2018
and now 2020 and that uh some things
changed from
16 and 18 i assume there's always going
to be some minor changes here and there
but you said that you're not allowed to
talk to them
and you're not allowed to walk around
the polling place
which was contrary to the policy set
forth
by the secretary of state so
were you given any reason as to why
you were being told on the day of
implementation of these policies
why you were not allowed to do what
great questions
set forth in those policies as far as
seeing the receiving process
as far as you know you're there
obviously to observe
um were you given any you said that you
were prevented
how were you prevented what did they say
perfect did they give you a reason as to
why
you couldn't do that the inspector at
each of the polling locations
after i would come in and i would show
them my official credentials
they would then give me instructions and
this went on in both locations
that i served at where the inspector
would tell us that
here's the seat where you can sit in
you can't walk around and talk to any of
the poll workers or any of the voters
and if you do want to go anyplace uh in
the facility
uh in the polling location that you have
to ask me first
uh and i will assign a poll worker to
you for you to be able to walk around
with
now that's kind of so he was advised of
a policy he's acting like he was
handcuffed
20 general election manual that was put
out by the secretary of state
which said if an observer arrives at the
bowling location the inspector should
number one welcome the observer and
thank them for their service
number two instruct them that they can
observe
operations but must maintain at least a
six
foot of physical distance from voters
number three work with the observer to
find a
few optimal locations in the vote center
in the vote center the the funny thing
is this guy's acting like like that's
the
they find the locations on the first day
this guy's like yeah on the seventh day
that i was there
you know they didn't work with me to
find locations is that well no it's like
the sixth day of early voting they've
already figured that out they already
have people sitting in certain places
very bizarre testimony very very strange
um we'll get back to rudy momentarily i
do want to thank the chunky avenger
for gifting so many beautiful
subscriptions
over on twitch and we are working our
way towards hopefully opening up some
phone lines we are at
68 new members and subs i also want to
add
three more folks just signed up on my
website joinpacman.com
uh putting us at 71. angel is asking a
good question
is this a real hearing or a press
conference designed to look like a
hearing
listen um it's a hearing with
republicans only
and only republican lawyers and
nobody's under oath so it it's not
really a hearing no
an unfriendly how so
um as a republican poll worker
which i had i had a badge that i had to
wear that said that i was a republican
uh poll observer um i felt uh
intimidated by um oh my god he was now
now they're arguing intimidation okay by
the way this guy's been
how long has this guy been talking let
me see here this guy's been talking for
i guess about uh
for 42 minutes he was supposed to go 10
minutes it's it's crazy what's going on
i mean it's true it's
completely insane what's going on ryan
suggests maybe the first drawer filled
up
and they had to use other drawers just a
thought fair question
dennis says has this guy just sweated
all his hair dye away
i don't that's unfair that's that's
that's ad hominem when does mcconaughey
show up a real lawyer
i've only been a lawyer for 15 years
seems to me like his witness is merely
saying that his expectations
of being a poll watcher weren't met yet
this guy didn't like how it all worked
essentially is is what uh i guess the
case
the case that he's making here the the
the claims are all
very very strange and sort of
overlapping
and internally conflicting now they're
clapping for this guy
they also have a badge identified
democrat
um some of them did some
didn't so it wasn't consistent but you
were
they all had to come in with a um
identification
uh they the republicans were one color
the democrats were another color
um whoa i
when when i was at the election facility
there for the short period of time uh
that a democrat was there
which uh they came in like about two in
the afternoon we stayed until from two
to like four
in the afternoon there was a democrat
there she was sitting right next to me
uh the extent of the conversation i had
with her started and ended with the fact
that
the democratic let's just take a look at
this same hearing from a different
angle just to see like what's going on
to this guy's right
um it's not any less crazy on this side
i mean still like i guess one mask i see
uh it's not it's not any less wacky
with this reverse angle um
[Music]
yeah i do think there is something like
listen
i don't think that um
oh somebody here ad hominem means to
counter with one's own arguments
no that that's not that's not what it
means that's weird
i do think that there is some
calculation in putting the woman with
the leather pants in this position
because people won't stop talking about
her on any of my streams or on the
streams that uh that that this is
happening on so i i don't think that
that's
a mere coincidence i think that that's
that's quite fair to say
um okay drummer shy says the trump
campaign spent so much money on these
failing recounts and the states are
getting quite frankly free money
here's something super interesting oh
let's listen to the transition to the
next witness hold on
it's been such a long day and we've had
a number of witnesses that have had to
go to work and have had to leave
um so if if i'm going to give you a
couple minutes if i call your name and
you're not here we'll go on to the next
person but
we're going to try and work through this
entire name list next individual up is
diane sarah
is diane still here
so as they find another witness one of
the things that was fascinating is that
the trump campaign paid
3 million bucks for a partial recount in
two wisconsin counties
and they did that and it added 87 votes
for joe biden so they paid 3 million
joe biden got 87 votes so in essence
trump's donors paid 34
000 per additional vote for joe biden if
you can imagine
but it's not a waste of money for trump
because trump raised 6 million
used 3 million for the recounts and then
kept three million to pay off campaign
debt so trump's like
using this as one last big scam
so to speak and um they found they did a
partial recount and they found more
votes for
biden no masks here here is our next
witness let's see what this is all about
all right okay if you would please give
your name
and uh if if i'm just gonna ask you to
be
please be succinct about your
experiences
so please give your name and let's go
i'm dr judith
judith burns i'm a resident of maricopa
county
public educator for 40 years at both the
university and secondary levels of
education
a lot of coughing in there
i was an observer at the tabulation and
election center on two occasions
and a poll watcher in my community
on one day initially
i chose to do this as a civic duty
to my state into my country
and i believed in the process
she may cry i'm nervous because this
is so very very important
ma'am please don't be nervous it's just
it's just us normal people that you're
talking to
i know you said you're a teacher we're
nervous
[Laughter]
i won't check your grammar thank you
i observed at the election center on two
occasions both in the signature
verification room
and in the ballot processing room the
first day i was in
the signature verification room they
should say don't be nervous this is
meaningless you're not even under oath
and we're in a high school gym and it's
only just republicans who happen to be
legislatures this is meaningless
um told to stay in that spot
and i was facing a room full of
computers
that all i could see they had her facing
a blank wall just like dogs sometimes
will stand five inches from a wall
and look at a blank wall and you're like
what the hell is the dog doing it's
there's nothing there they had her
facing a black hole
a blank wall see anything and i was very
disturbed by this but wasn't really sure
what to do
i did ask celia who i believe is one of
the vice presidents
of operations with why they were like
that and i was told because they needed
to be set up that way due to the wiring
systems
so i was there again four days later
and the room was full of screeners
i was able to she might be nervous
because she's like isn't it illegal to
tell lies here and then they'll say
don't worry you're not under oath
computer screens which was maybe
six feet from me i could see it better
when i was able to stand up which i did
i kept looking at the screen because it
seemed very odd
and in the bottom right hand corner was
a yellow yellow banner
and i got to into a position where i
could see the yellow banner which said
low
confidence then i started paying much
closer attention to the signatures maybe
it meant low confidence in the poll
watchers
it didn't even make sense to me because
the signature
on the ballot that was being compared to
other signatures
didn't even resemble in any way
what they were comparing it to they were
completely
illegible they were just scribbles on
the ballot
and there were five screeners
screening low confidence ballots
for an entire afternoon that i was in
there
and i asked celia
um what the low confidence said and she
said just not to worry about that
that this was a new program that they
were testing
and okay so i continued watching
and um shortly after i talked with her i
had a few other questions and at that
time she suggested that i just sit down
at the table where we were in our little
area that we were supposed to remain
shortly after that there was a server
outage
and i believe on my affidavit i said
there was a power outage
but in actuality the lights were still
on it was whoa
that was a sworn affidavit that's an
admission of perjury isn't it guys
she said the power was out and the power
that's crazy
and rudy says it was sworn to check
um that was one of my questions then
when the computers came back up now as
you guys know of course
the point of perjury is there there has
to be intent if you
this is why people say things in court
all the time that aren't true
but you've got to prove they knew they
weren't true this is why this entire
concept of
these are sworn affidavits nobody would
ever get anything wrong
screeners all in one small area
they had some conversation and the
question from one of them to this
gentleman was
are you still doing what we were doing
meaning low confidence and he said no
i'm doing high confidence now
and he was out of those five screeners
he was then the only one that was doing
high confidence
signatures because he was the one i
could see
and at least that's what i surmised i
don't know
if it was coincidental that there was an
outage
and i don't really know what all that
means but what was evident
now she's so she originally reported as
a power outage what was a server outage
she later realized the lights were
actually on so it wasn't a power outage
and now she says she doesn't even really
know what it means that there was a
server outage
sworn affidavit witness testimony
the other experience um was in the um
oh i did ask celia um what happened to
those votes
we thought the entire time when they
were talking about server outages they
meant that the waiters and waitresses
were just on strike they weren't coming
in and serving food
i sort of i gave her a puzzled look
because it just it all seemed very odd
to me and i wasn't sure what to make
of the fact that there were all these
signatures that did not match
and then i was being told they were
being counted
the other area that i was in was in the
ballot processing room
we were in a room probably a little
smaller than this there had to have been
75 to 90 tables
well wait a second the previous guy said
the room was as big as this room
outside of different parties i was told
again
we were put i was probably as far away
as that black curtain
and the room was this big we could she
was enclosed in black
curtains in a two by two box surrounded
by black curtains
process for getting new ballots for them
to take out of the envelopes and
separate the ballot
and the envelope but what i noticed that
raised some questions for me was they
had their purses
at their table they had their cell
phones there
whoa during their break time um if they
did not get up and leave their table
they were able to rummage in their
purses
holy [ __ ] and uh in their backpacks
there as well and this bothered me i
wasn't
really sure so so she how is this
listen this woman was bothered by
someone looking at their purse
during a break hand the state to donald
trump my friends
the other thing i found interesting in
the whole process was when
um the press came in the second day that
i was there
the two women that had been in a quality
assurance role
is what i was told
and they i think they if they had over
votes or under votes on a ballot or an
issue with a ballot they would take
to those women all of the sudden they
were sitting at a table like this one on
each side
and they were processing the ballots
very close
to me oh so she was close to the process
set up a table
so the other guy said no republicans
were allowed close she says they were
they were very close
and um the press was able to take
pictures of us
so that they could see that there were
observers close to them and they would
get behind
me and they were directed that i was an
observer
so they were trying to get they used the
deceptive lens
to make it look like i was close now
bernie carrick can't stop sneezing
holy [ __ ] the
the other experience i had was in my
case yawning
at the um in the early voting
i got there very early wanted to make
sure i knew where i was supposed to be
seated and what i was going to be able
to see
yeah there's a really good point being
made uh in uh over on twitch
that the things she's talking about
aren't even really
worth lying about like it's just she
doesn't seem to have liked elements of
this she didn't like where a
photographer stood
she was at one point too close and at
one point too far from things she didn't
like that during breaks people had
purses
it's it's all you know the preferences
of these individuals
let me get us an updated number from the
standpoint of opening phones
we had an additional six people grab
twitch subs which puts us at 77
and we had an additional three people
grab website
memberships which puts us at 80. just as
a reminder i do want to hear from you
guys we're going to open the phone lines
hopefully at 100
and we've got this great new coupon code
fresh start
which saves you 70 percent at
joinpackman.com
uh i want to say thanks to tylan who
subscribed on twitch and said do not
forget
to use your free prime subs to support
independent journalism yeah whether it's
me or other independent journalists on
twitch
although i don't know who else is on
twitch you're basically taking money
from jeff bezos and giving it to
independent media that's a pretty
appealing
value proposition if you ask me uh jan
pointing or jan pointing out that this
is very much like saturday night live it
really is
and um none of this really makes
any sense at all and we're going to
listen to a little bit
a little bit more of it here and
reported that this was going on
this went on all day long in this
precinct
there was masking tape there was tape
somebody had gone to get a dauber to to
try to get the envelopes to should only
be duct tape when i
when i would watch people put them in i
the envelope would open and about i so i
don't know if those ballots fell out
if those ballots were ever counted i'm
not really sure what it meant
but what i what i ascertained from all
of this
was that there were just some odd things
going on and i was concerned
i was concerned both at the tabulation
center by the fact that that's enough
for me to overturn the state
she was concerned that i was looking at
low confidence signatures
and was told that those votes would be
counted and then going to a precinct
and seeing that envelopes were
being taped with masking tape for an
entire day and
i was very concerned about that when i
volunteered to serve as an
observer i did so with the belief
in the process and the system
that belief has been shaken by this
experience
to its core and i'm truly concerned
for our future as a nation and as a
state
what kind of a country are we if during
breaks people have access to their
phones we will not allow
this country to fall findings that you
receive today
from the many many people that are
willing to come forward
and state what they have observed
that you will make an honest decision
so that the integrity what are they even
deciding the state's been certified like
who's she even talking to what decision
is there to make
dr burns thank you very much for your
courage and your service
curry mr giuliani do you have any
questions
so how many days were you there ms burns
i was two days
at the tabulations and election center
and one day at a poll center
poll watching which which was first uh
the tabulations and elections
two days there two days at the
tabulation center yes and then
after that at the electoral the first
day of early voting
so at the tabulation center most of the
time it was hard for you to see anything
right i wasn't sure the other place it
was too easy to see
she was too close you were there to make
observations of
the examination of the male in balance
weren't you correct
to see if they were appropriate right
filled out
whether the signal should look right
address there name there
did you ever get to see any one of them
not one not one
not one so how many people in this
center in the ballot processing room
there were
approximately 90 tables
and it was a very simple size room
and the first day i was there there
might have been maybe
50 to 60 people in the room
50 to 60 tables with two people at each
table
the next day i went was during the week
and it was also the day when the press
was coming
so all the tables were quite full
so how many republican observers were
there in addition to you
we were allowed one republican and one
other party um in the room that's the
other party
for the entire room for the entire she
doesn't want to mention the democratic
i made the mistake after lunch of going
into the room
not knowing that somebody else had ever
signed to that room and i was told to
leave
and you were expected to cover 90 tables
yes
and you you're you know the funny thing
about all of this is that these are the
observers right
you've then got your poll workers which
are all sorts of people you know
in boston it's common that you have
police officers as poll workers
you have republican poll workers and
democratic poll workers
and why is it that if everything is off
the rails
the only people who are talking about it
are the republican observers
but the poll workers you know you've got
this one example of uh
what was her name michelle melissa
carone or whatever the
these are just the volunteers you think
all of these you know police officers
public servants people who who are there
as poll workers
they're just going to allow all this all
these lies to happen and they're just
and they would and so that when each
table got their tub
of i think it was an interesting event i
think it was a tub of cream
they were all open they had already been
opened and i did ask
somebody where these ballots come from
who opens them and she said they come
from the mail room
and i started to ask another question
and
one question was about our limit that we
were allowed to ask when i started to
ask another question
she walked away from me
so they were so someone was sort of this
was sort of
kind of like the approach of your
governor and secretary of state
see no evil right
feel no evil just ignore it
so the ballots came in in a tub did the
other ballots come in a tub
it was mixed in actually with uh
unsalted grass-fed butter in the tub it
was ballots
cured ballots and then butter all the
ballots that were coming in what did
they come in and what were they carried
in
they were like those tubs with the
handles the shallow tubs that were
handled and they were rubber band
and but they were they were
no i say that the normal ones that came
in were sealed
we have no way of knowing listen these
were see these weren't sealed and that's
very suspicious oh is that because the
all the others were sealed well no we
have no idea we don't know if they're
supposed to be sealed or not but these
were unsealed and that's really
suspicious
being brought to the tables could you
see whether they were open
or closed they were all opened they were
all ready all
of them all the ballots were open they
would the people at the table
would open them up and pull the ballot
uh check the number on the ballot
and the envelope so that they coincided
they would separate them they would have
their pile of ballots
and the envelopes and at that point they
were separated
so they didn't really have to open the
envelope theoretically they had to just
weird because rudy's entire case so far
is based on people opening the envelope
now he's like nobody had to open any
envelopes well your entire original
story was based on envelopes being
opened
the district in which they're voting his
case i'm using that term
right the inner envelope is called a
secure envelope
there was one envelope it was the green
envelope
oh that's genius rudy for a month has
been making
this case about two envelopes this woman
goes
two envelopes no there's just one
envelope what are you talking about rudy
if you're on board no there were not two
envelopes
maybe correct the green envelope
this is the best rudy's like strike
everything this woman said
inside because your ballot is supposed
to be anonymous
there were not two envelopes there was
one envelope because that may explain
why they were open
right now that's part of the conspiracy
the system where they
opened them but we signed the back of
our eyes
look at rudy he's perplexed it's the
mailing
address he's like [ __ ] i've been talking
about two envelopes for a month now and
this woman says
there were no there was just one
envelope i hand carried mine and put it
but you do it was it a mail invoke
yes well was there an envelope you had
to put the ballot in
yes a green envelope one envelope
one envelope and the naked bound correct
no no duplicate and
in other states that i have literally
yes yes there were two envelopes
okay so when it came in it was open
already yes
it's too much it was separated so before
the problem was two envelopes
now the problem is there's one but it
was open
envelopes are i believe are scanned
in and the signature verification room
is where that that number that is on the
this is too good envelope coincides with
the signature and those are scanned in
so maya
hey jenna can you uh cancel everything
we've done
about two envelopes just get get delete
it all
any uh anything that's on the ballot
they only have the signature and they
are checking it
checking it against other signatures it
is comedy gold
since previous voting did you see that
done
that's what i was trying to see in the
sun no but i didn't
i was making every effort to see that
but so did you see that part
now i also didn't see that and you were
the only republican doing that too
i was the only one so if you weren't
doing it nobody else was
correct so that was all being done
secretly
well secretly meaning without any
republican observers
right huge secret just a room full of 90
poll workers
14 computers there and they
was full and and they were all i
couldn't see anything so how many how
many of these ballots
would you estimate went into the vote
without a republican getting a chance
to even glimpse at the envelope as much
as i would like to answer that i
can't just guesstimate it was an
entitlement how long were you there
i was i was there two afternoons
for how long each afternoon uh four
hours
and how many ballots could they do in an
hour well
this was interesting some of them would
click click
click click without really looking at
them
they would just sort of glance at it and
go on to the next one and go on to the
next one
there was one gentleman that seemed
a little more intent on actually looking
at the signatures that he was so this
this is like crazy let me just
take a little bit of a break from this a
couple of things oh so people are
i see people coming in asking who this
guy is this is bernard carrick now he's
a convicted felon right he's like a
former
nypd guy uh and i believe
convicted felon no we're not pausing
guys this has been going on eight hours
we're not pausing the video
um that's that's bernard carrick he
seems to be working with rudy on on you
know who
who knows what and then the woman with
the leather pants i don't know who that
is people have asked if this woman
woman back here has four arms it looks
like she just has her arms
kind of like out of the sleeves that's
all uh and then this is jenna ellis over
here another one of donald trump's
lawyers that's the um
that's the crowd so listen we have two
events coming up this weekend that i
plan to stream
if possible trump rallies are starting
back up
reportedly this saturday donald trump
will be doing
a rally in georgia for the
senate races there kelly loffler or
lefleur depending on your preference and
um also um
the other the other uh david perdue i
guess it's a joint rally so trump
rallies are back on saturday
my plan is to cover it and on sunday we
will be covering
there is a debate scheduled between
rafael warnock
and kelly leffler in the georgia debate
the david perdue the sitting republican
running against john ossoff
is not appearing at any more debates
apparently
the last i heard he is not going to be
doing any more debates
and if you saw how badly the last one
went for him you would you would
understand why
so we may have saturday sunday streams
coming up and a lot of very very
interesting elements to be
watching so that's all going on let me
do an
update we have had an additional
15 twitch subs which puts us at 95
and then in addition to that we have had
four more oh my goodness we are at 99
website members join pacman.com if we
get one more
we will open phone lines and maybe even
go twitch exclusive
so uh we whoever wants to be that last
person
joinpakman.com the coupon code is
available i would love to hear from you
guys we haven't taken calls in a while
in the meantime let's just listen just a
little bit more
to what is being said here texted her
she asked me to write in
then i got very specific in my email i
was so
disturbed by what i had seen i went into
this
in good faith that people did the right
thing
and that's not what i saw i've never had
the opportunity to provide a civic
service like this before and i was truly
astounded at what i saw
and the way i was people were polite but
the way i was treated
go sit over there i was at that black
curtain and the closest table to me
was further away than i am from that
black curtain
and you did this for no compensation
and tell us the reason again you did it
i did it because i have
i'm a retired university professor
and i wanted to be involved in this
process
i believe in our country i believe in
this process
and i'm i'm so disappointed in what i
saw
you shocked i was shocked absolutely
shocked and at first i thought
maybe it's me i've not done this before
i don't
really know specifically what i should
be looking for but it didn't feel right
that's the key thing she wasn't even
sure what it was supposed to look like
she didn't know what she was supposed to
be observing but she didn't like a lot
of what she saw
i'm very sorry for what happened to you
shouldn't happen in america that's true
they're apologizing
more to this woman than they did for
a people who have alleged sexual assault
against them
rudy's rudy is more on his hands on his
knees apologizing to this woman than
we've seen actual victims of sexual
assault
not so fast members any questions
uh representative bartow thank you dr
burns
um this is really troubling i mean when
you think about
signature verification that's um so
basic
i just have a question about how this
works out from your observation
does each click mean that it was
accepted you're talking about the clicks
i i don't know so there could they could
be a click
that it's not accepted
good luck something that i i can't
answer i don't really know that
well if it wasn't accepted did do you
know
what happens to those ballots that were
not accepted that they go somewhere else
that you
observed where they would be adjudicated
probably
later on i found out that some of them
would go to somebody else and they would
follow up on them
but my thinking was there were so many
that were
that weren't even close to the signature
how could they possibly follow up on
those
so i don't really know where they went
and
um and the clicking was
i i didn't know all right my friends as
promised we have gotten to 100
website members and twitch subs
so we are going to open the phone lines
at davidpakman.com
discord before we get back to this as i
promised
we are going twitch exclusive for the
phone calls so please if you would like
to participate and listen only
uh go over to twitch.tv david pakman i'm
going to be pinching off
the youtube stream excuse me
and the facebook stream and we are going
exclusive to twitch twitch.tv
david pakman and go to davidpakman.com
discord to get into the waiting room
uh okay i will see everybody over at
twitch.tv
slash david pakman momentarily